2014 Europe's economic recovery is in
the doldrums GDP lies at one point four
percent for the eu28 in unemployment
remains in double digits at ten percent
to fix the rot investment plan to
re-energize the continent by generating
315 billion euros over three years was
unveiled by Commission President
jean-claude Juncker but at the halfway
point of the grand plan delivered on his
promises blah blah continued a 0 de la
dieta wazo kanave ODB pass ? paske SE
massa moo-coo on pants mmm ODB don't
level it is a pretty terminal trapeze up
and on a blue sky sample so an initial
injection 21 billion euros was secured
with the EU budget and european
investment bank money was put into
infrastructure and innovation projects
and finance was provided to SMEs the
Commission says that these investments
have triggered 100 billion euros worth
of investment but for so many peas that
investment has come at the cost of the
EES flagship research and innovation
project horizons 2020 I want for a full
funding for reisen 2020 and at the same
time I want a Younker plan to work I
don't want relabeling I wanted to take
on risky investment and it's not just
about the money it's about organizing
infesting so some wrinkles still need to
be ironed out but at least Europe's
regeneration is off to a start
[Music]
you